[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mon mari s'est fait vacciner bah oui
c'est un peu épais rideaux boulet sur
marne et la prairie les plus gros
lorraine languedoc cm pour les boules
non il ya eu 2 placebo
parce que tu sais les mantais pas sur le
bras les deux possibles
[Musique]
dans son jus 10 pour les vacances est
mort tu partiras tous savaient pas avec
toi c'est un peu dérangeant pour un
conte plein d'eau moi je veux le rebâtir
et prépare la merde
[Musique]
je vous le dis aussi pour tous les gens
qui arrêtaient pas qu'ils se sont faits
qui se sont pas fait injecter mais ils
n'ont pas arrêté de se faire des tests
vous avez de l'oxydé de graphène dans
les sinus
on a vu des têtes prendre feu partout
dans le monde actuellement et d'où est
ce qu'une tête prend feu
[Musique]
moi j'ai vu carrément une ligne de gens
allongés par terre avec les yeux qui
était sorti de la tête